[Musique]
j'ai commencé la voile parce que j'ai eu
la chance de grandir dans la forêt de
rambouillet et d'avoir
papa qui aimait beaucoup de bateaux et
des parents qui aimait aller en bretagne
et je crois que la première fois c'était
pour se débarrasser de nous dans mon
frère et moi le matin entre 8h et midi
pendant les grandes vacances
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir sur l'eau
probablement l'arrivée de ma première
route du rhum en 2010 qui était la
réalisation d'un rêve c'est vrai que
quand on habite et qui ont grandi en
région parisienne et et qu'on est
passionné de voile on peut rêver de
faire tous ces trucs là toutes ses
courses au large et
mené cette carrière là mais c'est pas du
tout évident d'y arriver donc
donc voilà c'est le graal de faire une
grosse virum donc quand on boucle sa
première route du rhum c'est c'est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel c'est
réaliser un rêve
cette année c'est de terminer la transat
jacques vabre dans les cinq six
possibles et se préparer pour le tour du
monde l'année prochaine ce sera ma
troisième participation consécutive
c'est la course la plus dure en course
au large et le terminer ça sera déjà
bien et en général quand on termine de
vendée globe avec un bon bateau de toute
façon on a un bon classement et
et tout le monde est content